elle se sentait pas en sécurité chez
elle donc elle venait demandait à venir
chez moi parce qu'elle se faisait on va
dire amoché par euh son comp on a des
témoignages qui nous racontent que il
continue après leur séparation à se
disputer qu'elle a encore peur de lui
euh un témoin dira qu'il a entendu cet
homme dire un jour qu'il allait la tuer
ainsi que le petit donc on a ses
[Applaudissements]
éléments mercredi 5 octobre 2005 bésier
dans
l'éros Rachid Mansouri 26 ans vient
rendre visite à son fils saphir 3 ans et
à son excagne Marjoline Lalande 21
ans depuis leur séparation la mère et le
petit garçon vivent en plein
centrre-eville rue de valm dans dans un
modeste
appartement mais au pied de l'immeuble
rachide remarque un détail
anormal on va constater que de façon
inhabituelle les volets de margeoline
sont fermés il sonne à l'interphone
personne ne répond il tente de joindre
la margeline la maman de son petit
saphir sans
réponse il téléphone il envoie des
textau toujours aucune Ré il est très
inquiet Rachid monsouri rentre chez lui
peut-être que Marjoline l'appellera dans
la soirée pour le rassurer il décide de
revenir le lendemain
matin jeudi 6 octobre il est midi
toujours sans nouvelle il se rend à
l'école de sa
fille il demande à une employée de
l'école de se renseigner d'aller voir si
son enfant y est on lui répond que non
il commence à être sérieusement
inquiet Rachid Mansouri fonce à
l'hôpital de beziier marjolen ous saphir
ont peut-être eu un
accident là encore recherche qui va
rester
veine puisque aucun élément ne vient
confirmer ses craintes à savoir une
hospitalisation mais où sont passés
Marjoline et
saphire rachide Mansouri retourne rue de
valmi
une voisine le fait rentrer dans
l'immeuble il se précipite à la porte de
l'appartement de son
excagne il possède un jeu de clé tente
de s'introduire dans l'appartement mais
s'aperçoit que finalement un autre
verrou qui clot cette porte est fermé
Rachid Mansouri descend chez magaliie la
voisine de Marjoline qui habite juste en
dessous et il lui dit écoute la seule
solution maintenant ça va être d'essayer
de rentrer par l'extérieur parce que
j'ai j'ai pas les j'ai pas les clés j'ai
pas accès au lieu et depuis depuis hier
je n'arrive pas à la joindre je suis
inquiet
elle lui prêtera une chaise il monte par
la fenêtre et donc il va de façon un peu
acrobatique réussir à passer du 2e au 3e
par
[Musique]
l'extérieur
il enfonce la
fenêtre arrive à pénétrer dans
l'appartement il ouvre l'armoire pour
vérifier qu'ils ne sont pas partis en
voyage en portant leurs
affaires et il voit que les affaires
sont toujours dans l'armoire Rach tourne
alors la tête et découvre
l'inimaginable son fils est étendu en
travers du lit inerte lu saisit le pied
et à ce moment il sent qu'il est
froid il constate que le visage de son
enfant est bleu et tout bleu il comprend
alors que saphir est
mort l'enfant j
étranglé avec le fil électrique de la
lampe de
chevet complètement affolé rachsouris se
précipite alors dans la pièce d'
côté la Chambre passe par le séjour voit
qu'il y a par terre
Marjoline il découvre le corps de
marjolinee étendu sur le dos elle est
dans le salon la jeune femme est
morte Rachid s'enfuit il descend dans la
rue dans un état que vous
imaginez il bouscule et frappe au
passage
de malheureux piétons qui passaient dans
le coin il crie dans la rue il se
précipite chez
lui il tombe sur sa mère il lu raconte
tout la découverte qui qui a été
faite il hurle mon fils est mort mon
fils est
[Musique]
mort au même moment rue de valmi un
voisin appelle le commissariat de
bzier les policiers arrivent sur place
il découvre la scène de crime et font
les premières constatations marjolen git
sur le dos elle porte un jein et des
baskets une couverture recouvre presque
entièrement son
visage en s'approchant il s'aperçoiv
qu'un bout de cette couverture est
carrément enfoncé au fond de la gorge de
la victime ce qu' laisse supposer
qu'elle a qu'elle a été
étouffée dans la chambre d'à côté les
policiers découvrent le cors sans vie du
petit saphir il y a autour du coup de
l'enfant un fil électrique le fil
électrique de la lampe de chevet la
lampe de chevet elle est elle est elle
est elle est pas tombée elle est
droite fait notable dans l'appartement
tout semble en
ordre la scène de crime
elle ressemble
à quelque chose d'apaisé pas de trace de
bagarre pas de trace de lutte rien n'est
déplacé rien n'est cassé il y a pas de
trace d'ffraction sauf que les clés de
margeoline sont introuvables le
meurtrier est-il reparti avec son
trousseau et si oui
pourquoi les experts de la police
scientifique investissent les lieu le
tueur a peut-être laissé des traces
derrière lui la police technique et
scientifique fait son travail de de de
fourmis c'est-à-dire de recueillir tout
ce qui pourrait être empreinte digitale
trace ADN cheveux poil trace de
transpiration Mo évidemment et il
découvre dans la chambre de l'enfant
sous le lit un
Mo de
joint un joint de cannabis qui a été
fumé qui a été consumé aucune empreinte
suspecte n'est relevé sur la scène de
crime quant au Cellé ils sont envoyés au
laboratoire pour y être
analysé à abéier la nouvelle de la mort
de Marjoline et de saphire se répand
parmi les proches
en fin d'après-midi Paulette Lalande la
mère de la victime apprend la terrible
nouvelle par une amie
elle me dit c'est Marjoline et saphire
j'ai qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui
se passe elle me dit ils sont morts oh
là là mais alors j'ai eu une douleur
dans le dos en bas des reins jusqu'à la
tête ça a été mais alors quelque chose
de terrible j'ai cru que j'étais
paralysé puis bon je me suis retrouvé
dehors je sais pas comment en train
d'hurler pleurer Paulette Lalande ne
sait pas encore que sa fille et son
petit-fils ont été tués dans des
circonstances particulièrement
atroce les corps sont transportés à
l'institut médico-légal de Montpellier
l'autopsie du corps de marjolen révèle
l'extrême violence de ce meurtre la
jeune femme est morte
étouffée mais a été aussi
frappé le médecin légiste constate que
Marjoline Lalande a une fracture auocis
qu'elle a un une blessure à l'arrière du
crâne qui aura provoqué un traumatisme
crânien à partir de ces éléments les
enquêteurs peuvent esquisser le
déroulement du meurtre
elle est bousculé elle tombe en arrière
elle se fracture le coccis elle heurte
sa tête en arrière et ce qui
expliquerait la présence de cet
hématome et étant inanimé sur le sol le
tueur a pu l'étouffer en enfonçant un
coin de couverture profondément dans sa
gorge une mort lante sans doute très
douloureuse très très angoissante ça a
pris plusieurs minutes quant à saphir 3
ans l'autopsie confirme qu'il a bien été
étranglé avec le fil de sa lampe de
chevet probablement pendant son
sommeil le médecin légiste établit enfin
une fourchette pour la date et l'heure
des décès l'enfant et la mère sont morts
entre le mardi 4 22h et le mercredi 5
octobre 11h du
[Musique]
matin drame familial crime de sadic
règlement de compte les enquêteurs sont
perplexes comment quelqu'un a pu ettre
un crime aussi atroce ils évacuent très
rapidement l'hypothèse du rur puisqu'il
n'y a pas de trace
desffraction c'est donc quelqu'un que
manifestement Marjoline connaît et c'est
donc quelqu'un que Marjoline a fait
monter chez
[Musique]
elle puisque le meurtrier semblait
connaître la jeune femme les enquêteurs
passe sa vie au crible au commissariat
les auditions des proches
s'enchaînent en apprenant la nouvelle du
drame les amis de la victime sont
stupéfaits c'est pas compréhensible en
plus elle avait toute la vie devant elle
comment est-ce possible qu'une chose
comme ça arrive les policiers veulent
savoir qui était Marjoline qui elle
fréquentait et surtout qui aurait pu en
vouloir à la jeune mère et son fils
apparemment elle menait une vie
tranquille la vie de Marjoline au moment
des meurtres est une vie bien rangée
bien structurée malgré son jeune âge
c'était une bonne mère tout le monde l'a
écrit comme une bonne mère elle
s'occupait de son très bien de son fils
c'est le nombrile du monde
saphire puis c'est un enfant qui qui est
magnifique qui est rigolo qui est vivant
qui bouge c'est bien ça é tout le temps
avec toujours toujours sortait toujours
toujours la poussette marjolen ne
travaillait pas elle vivait du RMI et
des allocations de M isolé des revenus
modestes mais dont elle se
contentait selon ses amis sa seule
passion était une collection
d'armes très
particulière Marjoline Lalande avait une
passion pour les Sabres les katanas
qu'elle avait acheté au marché de
béziier et d'ailleurs elle avait projeté
d'en racheter d'autres elle avait ce
petit plaisir les policiers sont
intrigués dans l'appartement les six
sabres de Marjoline ont disparu ont-ils
été volés ou les aurait-elle vendu il
ressort de l'enquête de voisinage que
margeline ne se serait jamais séparé de
ces sabres japonais auquel elle tenait
particulièrement mais ce n'est pas la
seule chose qui interpelle les policiers
le téléphone de margeline aussi a
disparu un modèle dernier CR avec
appareil photo pour prendre des clichés
de son fils elle y tenait beaucoup B
elle peut pas s'en
passer si jamais le petit tombe si
jamais le le petit a quelque chose il
faut vite appel le médecin il faut
appeler rachide bon voilà c'est elle
peut pas s'en passer elle a besoin d'un
téléphone de toute façon le téléphone de
Marjoline Lalande est éteint impossible
pour les enquêteurs de le localiser six
sabres et un téléphone ont disparu le
vol serait-il le mobile de ce double
meurtre mais un nouveau témoignage va
mettre les policiers sur une autre piste
Chantal la mère d'une amie de Marjoline
est entendu par les enquêteurs et révèle
une information de taille depuis
quelques temps la jeune femme se sentait
en danger à tel point qu'elle avait pris
des dispositions elle a tellement peur
que elle sarve d'un couteau qu'elle a en
permanence dans son sac et ce n'est pas
tout les enquêteurs vont apprendre que
marjolen avait récemment contacté une
avocate c'était 15 jours avant sa
mort cette avocate elle a été entendue
par les services de police et elle a dit
qu'elle avait
peur et qu'elle voulait quitter la ville
elle se sentait menacée elle ne m'a pas
confié le nom de la personne qui la
menaçait de qui marjolinee avait-elle
peur et pourquoi les policiers n'en
sauront pas
plus mais rapidement ils vont découvrir
quelque chose qu'il n'imaginaent pas et
cela concerne l'un des trè proche de
Marjoline en enquêtant sur l'entourage
de la jeune femme les policiers se
rendent compte que Rachid Mansouri le
père éplloré à un casier judiciaire bien
rempli les policiers se renseignent
forcément sur l'exmi l'excagnon de de
Marjoline Lalande et s'aperçoiv qu'il a
été condamné plusieurs fois pour
violence pour petit trafic de stupéfiant
voilà un garçon qui la terreur de son
quartier euh voilà un garçon qui a un
comportement assez inquiétant et voilà
un garçon qui euh a un passé de violence
euh assez
conséquent et parmi les nombreuses
condamnation de Rachid Mansouri l'une
d'elles retient l'attention des
policiers des faits particulièrement
choquants Rachid Mansouri n'a pas hésité
à kidnapper un individu qui lui devait
de l'argent et après avoir entraîné sa
victime dans un appartement Rachid
Mansouri l'a attaché à une chaise et l'a
battu pendant plusieurs he c'est un type
qui a été
sequestré par r Monsouris qui a été
humilié et qui était obligé de
réciter des versets du Coran et il était
attaché par le coup avec une laisse de
chien pour ses
violencessouri a été condamné à 9 mois
de prison ferme
alors l'homme pourrait-il être lié à la
mort de Marjoline et de sa fille
s'agirait-il en fait d'un drame familial
les enquêteurs le convoquent au
commissariat mais lors de son audition
le père du petit saphire est totalement
effondré Rachid est sous le choc Rachid
est très choqué il est meurtri
il il ne supporte pas l'idée qu'on ait
pu tuer son enfant et voici ce que
déclare Rach concernant son emploi du
temps pour le soir du drame vers 19h30
j'ai ramené Saffire chez sa mère et je
suis reparti chez mes parents il va
dîner chez ses parents c'est le Ramadan
il fait le repas en famille le soir j'ai
dû aller voir un copain en rentrant j'ai
dû passer chez
Abdel le temps de vérifier son alibi
Rachid Mansouri ressort libre du
commissariat mais au même moment les
policiers de Bier ille un témoignage
capital il s'agit de magaliie la voisine
qui habite l'appartement en dessous de
celui de
Marjoline la nuit du drame elle ne
dormait pas sa fille venait de la
réveiller et elle a remarqué quelque
chose elle dit que cette nuit là c'est
la nuit de mardi à mercredi vers 2h du
matin elle voit dans le
couloir la lumière euh s'éteindre puis
s'allumer et le deuxième point elle a
entendu du bruit le bruit d'une serrure
que l'on ferme ou que l'on ouvre à 2h du
matin 2h du matin l'horaire correspond à
l'heure de la mort donnée par le légiste
Magalie a-t-elle entendu le tueur
prendre la
fuite au fil de son audition la voisine
va plus loin le soir de sa mort
Marjoline avait rendez-vous avec un
homme un petit ami devenu encombrant lui
avait-elle dit
de jours avant la découverte du corps de
de
Marjoline cette dernière lui a indiqué
qu'elle allait rompre avec un jeune
homme de 17 ans avec qui elle
entretenait une relation épisodique
depuis depuis quelques jours les
policiers évidemment vont chercher à
identifier ce jeune homme et
malheureusement elle ne connaît pas son
nom ni même son prénom elle donne une
description physique elle donne des
renseignements notamment elle sait qui a
un certain passé judiciaire donc les
policiers se disent qu'il est peut-être
possible de l'identifier via le fichier
Canonge qui est un fichier qui détient
un certain nombre de d'images de
délinquants et là face à cette série de
photos elle reconnaît Mohammed shaiib 17
ans comme étant l'amant supposé de de
Marjoline
[Musique]
Lalande Mohamed
les policiers le connaissent bien c'est
un petit délinquant de
quartier un déjà connu la justice des
enfants qui a déjà fait des choses pas
très avoables il a volé il a menacé
d'armes même des pistolets à PL et il y
a 4 mois de cela il a été placé en garde
à vue et on a découvert chez lui un
certain nombre
d'objets qu'à l'évidence il avait
volé Mohamed shaiib a déjà été condamné
à 18 mois de prison dont 17 avec surc
après un séjour en centre éducatif
renforcé il est retourné chez ses
parents dans le centre de Bézier à un
quart d'heure à pied de chez
margelain les policiers send
immédiatement et c'est la mère de
Mohamed qui les
accueille il frapp à la porte j'ouvre la
porte ils me disent on cherche est-ce
que Mohamed est là dit non pourquoi bon
ils ont pas voulu me dire le pourquoi ah
ouais j'étais inquiète parce que je me
dis qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi pourquoi
il le recherche pourquoi pourquoi ils
sont venus le chercher et là c'est un
petit détail qui attire l'attention des
enquêteurs il trouve entre les mains du
Père un téléphone
portable exactement le même modèle que
celui qui a disparu chez
marjolette un peu spontanément les
policiers interrogent le père en disant
mais d'où vient ce téléphone est-ce que
c'est à vous est-ce que vous l'avez
acheté vous l' achetez où vous l'
achetez depuis quand et cetera et le
père s'emmêle un peu les pinceaux en
disant mais non c'est pas moi c'est
c'est ma femme qui me l'a donné c'est
elle qui a mis la puce dedans et cetera
enfin bref c'est confus il s'avère que
après vérification ce téléphone
appartient à
Marjoline que fait le téléphone de
Marjoline laland chez les parents de
Mohamed shaib entendu au commissariat sa
mère se justifie ce portable c'est
Mohamed qui le lui a donné j'avais déjà
donné à la base bien
avant l'argent pour qu'il puisse me
procurer un portable parce que j'étais
sans portable comment Mohamed shaiib
s'est procuré le téléphone sa mère est
immédiatement interrogée sur l'emploi du
temps de son fils la nuit du drame et
voici ce qu'elle
déclare bah j'ai dit à peu près le son
emploi du temps que bon il était à la
maison et que bon en plein ramadan donc
il mangeait puis après il ressortait il
allait toujours au quartier au même
quartier où il y a tous les jeunes
là-bas sa maman dit il est rentré entre
1h30 et
2h ce qui correspond à la fourchette qui
a été fixé par le médecin légiste
concernant les heures de décès de
Margoline et de saphire shahib a offert
le téléphone de Margoline à ses parents
et il n'était pas chez lui le soir du
drame il devient immédiatement le
suspect numéro 1 dans le double meurtre
de la rue de
[Musique]
valmi tous les services de police de la
région sont sur les traces de Mohamed
shaiib mais ils ne chercheront pas
longtemps car le jeune homme n'est pas
très loin ça pas été difficile de
retrouver il est calé au quartier avec
son petit vélo et son petit joint et sa
canette de bière il est 21h15 7h à peine
après la découverte des corps les les
policiers lui demandent de les suivre
Mohamed se laisse interpeller sans
difficulté le jeune homme est placé en
Gard et à l'évidence il n'a pas l'air
très inquiet on lui signifie la raison
pour laquelle il est placé en garde vue
savoir l'omici ce qui n'est pas rien et
lui tout de suite ses premiers mots
c'est nous sommes dans une histoire de
fou Mohamed en bloc oui il sait avec
Marol depuis quelques temps mais non il
ne l'a pas tué leur dernier rendez-vous
c'était la veille de la mort dit-il il
dit qu'il a vu pour la dernière fois
celle avec qui il avait noué une
relation amoureuse le lundi 3 octobre
justement pour lui signifier qu'il en
avait marre la relation qu'il entendait
rompre mais il y a une autre raison pour
laquelle Mohamed voulait quitter
Marjoline le jeune homme craignait la
violence de Rachid
Mansouri j'avais peur que Rachid s'en
prenne à nous en apprenant que nous
avions une
relation shib raconte au policiers qu'il
n'est resté qu'une heure au domicile de
Marjoline le lundi veille de sa mort et
il est catégorique lorsqu'il est parti
la jeune fille et sa fille était vivant
à ce stade les policiers ont un suspect
important Mohamed shaiib ils n'ont pas
d'aveu ils n'ont pas grand-chose à lui
servir en terme d'éléments scientifiques
mais ils ont une sorte de de flair de
policier les policiers perquisitionnent
l'appartement des parents de Mohamed
shib à la recherche d'indice matériel
ben en fait ils sont venus avec Mohamed
donc ils sont montés dans la chambre au
milieu des affaires de shahib les
enquêteurs font plusieurs découvertes
accablantes les enquêteurs trouvent dans
la chambre de Mohamed un vanity avec à
l'intérieur un chargeur de téléphone
respond à celui de
maroline juste à côté sur une étagère il
découvre un couteau à CR d'arrêt et pas
n'importe lequel il tombe sur le un
couteau de défense que la victime margol
avait l'habitude d'avoir dans son sac et
ce n'est pas tout un peu plus loin dans
la chambre de la sœur de Mohamed les
enquêteur tomb sur un véritable Buttin
les objets qui ét important aux yeux de
Marjoline à savoir les Sabres les
katanas qui était sa collection
personnelle et un élément important le
lecteur
DVD qui avait été acheté pour saphir
donc bien entendu ça confirme toujours
dans l'esprit de l'enquêteur le fait que
le vol est est le premier mobile du
crime puisqu'on a déjà trouvé la veille
de téléphone portable immédiatement
entendu sur la présence de ces objets
Mohamed ne démonte pas un instant oui
ces objets ont bien appartenu à
margeoline mais il ne les a pas
volés ces objets il dit qu'ils ont qu'il
les a achetés à Marjoline les Sabres il
dit je les ai achetés à
margeoline selon lui la transaction se
serait faite la veille du drame il
indique aux enquêteurs qu'en réalité il
vient pour mettre un terme à la relation
avec
Marjoline puis
Marjoline lui dit écoute j'ai des objets
à vendre est-ce que tu veux bien m'en
débarrasser et
essayer de me donner un peu d'argent
contre contre ces objets Mohamed aurait
acheté ces objets pour une centaine
d'euros et si Marjoline les lui a vendu
c'est qu'elle avait un besoin pressant
d'argent seulement cette version va
rapidement être contredite par ses
proches il ressort de l'enquête que elle
TI très bien ses comptes tant si bien
que elle ne dépasse jamais le découvert
autorisé de moins de
100 mohamedib ditil la vérité pour le
savoir les enquêteurs se penchent sur
son emploi du temps le soir du double
meurtre et sans le savoir l'homme va
commettre une erreur lourde de
conséquence il indique je ne suis pas
sorti dans la soirée du mardi 4 au
mercredi 5 octobre sauf ce qu'il ne sait
pas c'est que la mère de Mohammed shahib
a été interrogé et elle au contraire se
souvient parfaitement de sa soirée là et
puisqu'elle regardait son émission
favorite et elle a dit que Mohamed est
sorti non seulement il est sorti vers
20h mais qu'il est rentré vers 1h du
matin les enquêteurs informment alors
Mohamed shahib de la version donnée par
sa mère il est resté sans voix il sit
contredit tout le temps et là Mohamed
SHB mis en face de cette contradiction
est obligé de reconnaître que ce soir-là
il est bien sorti de domicile de ses
parents et euh qui a traîné dans le
quartier plus d'alibi des soupçons de
vol et des mensonges à répétition tout
semble accabler le jeune
homme les policiers ont en garde à vue
Mohamed shaiib chez lequel on retrouve
des affaires appartenantes à margolaine
un emploi du temps de Mohamed shib qui
est on ne peut plus flou et puis un
mobile c'est très probablement le vol
donc on a un suspect numéro 1 c'est
Mohammed shibb il y a pas d'avocat il se
retrouve tout seul avec des policiers
qui lui disent nous raconte pas de
salade on sait que c'est toi et on te
connaît bien parce que il y a 4 mois
encore tu étais déjà chez nous sans
témoins direct et sans preuve matériell
les policiers sont dans l'impasse ils
ont besoin d'aveux mais le jeune homme
clame toujours son in
les policiers s'intéressent alors à
l'arme du crime qui a servi à étrangler
saphire le fil de sa lampe de chevet
l'examen de cet indice va révéler une
chose étonnante ce fameux
nœud qui a été fait autour du coup du
petit saphire c'éta un nœud très
technique ça peut être un nœud marin ça
peut être un nœud d'équitation ce qu'on
appelle un nud d'attache un nud
les policiers font immédiatement le
rapprochement avec Mohamed shaiib et
pour cause en fouillant dans dans le
passé de Mohamed shahib il se rend
compte que ce dernier a effectué un
stage de de cheval à quelques dizaines
de kilomètres de Bézier dans un cas de
réinsertion au moment où celui-ci de
commencait à dériver dans la délinquence
ce stage shahib l'a fait quelques
semaines à peine avant les meurtres de
Marjoline et de saphire les policiers
interrogent les responsables du centre
ce nœud est-il utilisé en équitation
Mohamed shahib savait-il le
faire les moniteurs d'équitation indique
aux enquêteurs que Mohamed shahib qui a
fait qui a effectué des stages au centre
a appris nécessairement obligatoirement
à faire ce nœud de cheval un éducateur
va être extrêmement précis puisqu'il va
dire ça va devenir un nœud réflexe
c'està-dire que le nœud va être de façon
très naturel être exécuté par Mohamed
SHB comme
étant un nud très simple à exécuter le
juge d'instruction lui posera la
question est-ce que vous savez faire ce
n d'attache il va affirmer que
non les éducateurs diront le contraire
pour le juge et les policiers Mohamed SH
ment une fois de plus et rapidement de
nouveaux éléments vont renforcer leurs
[Musique]
soupçons
l'Institut génétique de Nantes rend son
rapport sur les cell de la scène de
crime les experts ont trouvé beaucoup
d'ADN dont celui de Mohamed SHB c'est le
cas sur la couverture qui a servi à
étouffer margeolain les scientifiques
ont découvert une trace de sang une
tâche de sang dans laquelle se met l'ADN
de marjolineand mais également l'ADN de
Mohamed shib mais dans des traces
infinit voà seulement cela ne prouve
rien shib il dit qu'il a des relations
sexuelles avec elle depuis un certain
temps et une voisine confirme que c'est
son petit ami et c'est son petit ami bon
voilà si vous vous couchez dans un lit
où il y a une couverture on trouve votre
ADN c'est pas plus compliqué que ça plus
compliqué à expliquer son ADN est aussi
découvert dans la chambre de sa fille
dans la chambre de l'enfant sous le lit
les policiers avaient découvert un M
d'un joint de cannabis or ce joint a de
façon formelle été fumé par Mohamed
SH il a fumé un joint dans la chambre du
petit alors que c'était quelque chose
d'inenvisageable interdit formellement
interdit puisque l'enfant est asmatique
on ne peut pas fumer dans la même
chambre que lui plus troublant sur les
még prélevés dans le cendrier du salon
les experts ont retrouvé n deib celui de
Mansouri mais aussi celui d'un trè homme
mystérieux on va découvrir un M qui
comporte l'ADN mélangé d'un
homme inconnu don l'ADN reste inconnu et
cet homme ne sera pas identifié mélangé
à l'ADN féminin bien sûr de la victime
qui est ce trè homme qui est passé chez
margeline pour l'UR les policiers n'ont
pas de réponse et la fa va connaître un
nouveau rebondissement qui va relancer
l'enquête dans leur dossier les
enquêteur découvre un élément de poids 2
ans avant sa mort Marjoline s'est rendue
au commissariat pour déposer une main
courante contre Rachid Mansouri le père
de saphir elle dit deux choses elle dit
que elle est
battue terrorisé par cet homme et elle
dit aussi que il est le possesseur d'un
double de ses clés il débarque chez moi
à l'improviste et je reçois des coups
j'ai toujours été battu par cet homme
d'ailleurs Marjoline s'était confié à sa
mère au sujet de Rachid justement et ben
elle m'a dit Rachid il a levé la main
sur moi alors là ça m'a pas plu du tout
donc on a été voir la l'assistante
sociale qu'elle avait à l'époque puis
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on protège ma
fille pour moi il l'avait battu ils
allaient continuer ça allait se terminer
mal ça je sais pas j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
peur pour elle après ce passage au
commissariat Marjoline est partie une
semaine se réfugier dans un foyer pour
femmes
battu quand elle est rentrée les coups
ont continué à tel point qu'un de ses
amis avait l'habitude de l'accueillir
dans ces moments de crise
elle se sentait pas en sécurité chez
elle donc elle venait elle demandait à
venir chez moi parce qu'elle se faisait
on va dire amoché
par
on a des témoignages qui nous racontent
que il continuent après leur séparation
à se
disputé qu'elle a encore peur de
lui un témoin dira qu'il a entendu cet
homme dire un jour qu'il allait la tuer
ainsi que le petit donc on a ces
éléments les enquêteurs tombent des n il
découvre un tout autre visage de Rachid
monsouri est l'homme dont mar
disait avoir si peur le juge le convoque
immédiatement mais rachsour reconnaî
qu'il y avait une relation tendue avec
de la violence il se bousculait tous les
deux il a reconnu il a reconnu toujours
il a toujours reconnu ça après son
audition Rachid monsouri ressort libre
du bureau du juge Mohamed shib lui est
toujours suspecté mais il va créer la
surprise
2 mois après les meurtres de Marjoline
et du petit saphire shahib est
auditionné par le juge pour préciser son
emploi du temps la nuit du crime et face
au magistrat la mémoire lui
revient il affirme au juge ça y est je
m'en
souviens j'ai passé la soirée avec des
amis en un premier temps et puis ensuite
j'étais avec une jeune fille qui se
promme Charline avec laquelle je suis
resté peut-être jusqu'à 1h 1h30 cette
nuit-là et Charline va dire ouais je me
souviens bien oui j'étais avec
lui on a fumé un peu de cheat on a
rencontré un tel elle donne le nom le
tel d'ailleurs sera entendu et
confirmera les avoir rencontrés la jeune
femme est formelle elle est restée avec
Mohammed jusqu'à 1h30 du matin elle s'en
souvient d'autant plus qu' a reçu un
coup de téléphone ce soir-là elle leur
dit que ce soir-là elle a reçu un appel
téléphonique de son papa qui
s'inquiétait de son absence au domicile
vers 23h30 minuit et elle indique
qu'elle a en rentrant visionné une série
américaine donc elle est sûr qu'elle est
diffusé ce
soir-là donc Mohamed shahib n'a pas
menti il était avec Charlen cette
nuit-là et donc s'il était avec Charlen
il a pas pu tuer
Marg les enquêteurs se seraient-ils
trompés Mohamed shahib serait-il
innocent très rapidement les policiers
vont faire les vérifications d'usage à
savoir vérifier que le le père de
Charlen l'a bien appelé il se rendent
compte que ça ça ne correspond pas que
c'était pas ce jour-là et surtout que la
série n'est pas diffusé le le mardi soir
comme elle l'a affirmé mais le lendemain
soir Charlen s'est trompée de date ou
alors elle a menti Mohamed shib n'a plus
d'aliipi du moins pour l'instant car un
nouveau suspect va bientôt faire parler
de
[Musique]
lui 3 mois après la mort de Marjoline et
de saphire une certaine Rachelle une
jeune fille placée en foyer d'accueil
vient voir les policiers l'un de ses
amis lui aurait fait des révélations
elle aurait entendu un certain Yannick
se vanter euh d'avoir été présent au
moment du vol des objets chez Marjoline
Lalande qui est ce Yannick a-t-il un
lien avec le double meurtre la piste est
prise au sérieux par les enquêteurs et
Yannick est entendu Yannick va démentir
il affirme n'être jamais aller chez
Marjoline rue de valmi depuis qu'elle y
habite ensuite il dit ne s'être jamais
vanté de quoi que ce soit et ensuite il
comprend pas il comprend pas pourquoi
cette histoire les enquêteurs se rendent
au foyer résidianic pour vérifier son
emploi du temps le soir du drame d'après
les registres il serait rentré à 22h30
mais impossible de le prouver avec
certitude et on a des témoignages de
gens qui disent dans le dossier si si on
pouvait parfaitement faire le mur et
d'ailleurs nous on a déjà fait le mur en
audition Yannick reconnaît qu'il a fait
le mur à deux reprises mais c'était
après les meurtres de marjolen et de sa
fille les policiers le croient et ne
poussent pas plus loin leurs
investigations la piste est
abandonnée 2 ans après les meurtres on
ne sait donc toujours pas avec certitude
qui a tué Marjoline lallande et son
petit garçon le mardi 4 octobre
s'agit-il de Rachid Mansouri son ex
compagnon déjà condamné pour violence de
Mohamed shib chez qui on a retrouvé les
objets de Marjoline et qui n'a pas d'Ali
fiable où s'agit-il du mystérieux 3è
homme dont on a retrouvé
l'ADN pour le juge aucun doute il n'y a
qu'un meurtrier potentiel
c'estib et voici ce qui selon lui
l'aurait poussé
auur
tout commence le lundi 3 octobre la
veille de la mort de Marjoline et de sa
[Musique]
fille que Mohamed aurait dérobé à Marj
son téléphone
portable mardi marjolen se rend compte
de cette disparition et elle connaî
l'identité du voleur c'est
Mohamed le mardi 4 au soir Mohamed ser
nouveau rendu chez Marjoline elle était
furieuse et il lui aurait demandé des
comptes et comme elle se laisse pas
faire la minette elle a dû lui dire bon
écoute c'est pas compliqué tu me rends
mon téléphone où je vais au flic parce
qu'elle se débrouillait toute seule elle
avait besoin de personne pour régler ses
comptes et là tout aurait dégénéré
Mohamed shahib qui est quand même connu
pour une certaine impulsivité une
certaine agressivité se serait retourné
contre elle l'aurait poussé elle serait
tombée se faisant mal au au coccist d'
la fracture
selon les enquêteurs Mohamed shahib
aurait ensuite paniqué à l'idée d'être
dénoncé pour le vol du téléphone et les
coups qu'il venait de porter à
Margoline car le jeune homme était en
surc il avait été condamné 6 mois
auparavant pour vol avec violence il
risquait donc de retourner en prison il
savait que s'il était à nouveau mêlé à
une affaire il pourraitre sanctionné par
un emprisonnement le surcil qui pait sur
sa tte en l'occurrence 17 mois de pour
tomber et c'est probablement pour ça
qu'il a basculé dans l'reur
marjoland serait tombé inconsciente
mohamedait profité de cette occasion
pour introduire dans sa bouche la
couverture etura
étouff après avoir achevé Marjoline
Mohamed serait allé fumer un joint de
cannabis dans la chambre à
coucher le petit saphire dormait juste à
côté il aurait alors décidé de le
supprimer
ayant conscience que l'enfant pouvait
être un témoin gênant il aurait ensuite
étranglé avec le fil du du cordon de la
lampe le jeune saphir
ensuite il P l'appartement il va prendre
les Katan les sabres japonais il va
prendre un couteau gothique il va
prendre un lecteur
DVD il referme le sac et il rentre chez
lui
[Musique]
pourtant du fond de sa cellule Mohamed
shahb continue toujours de nier est-il
coupable ou victime d'une terrible
erreur judiciaire c'est désormais à la
cour d'assis de l'héros d'en
[Musique]
décider le procès de Mohamed shahib
s'ouvre le 22 septembre 2008 à
Montpellier et dès le départ débats sont
très mal engagés pour
lui il est agressif violent il insulte
tout le monde il se fait passer pour la
victime mais en
insultant l'expert psychologue va
enfoncer le clou en dressant le portrait
d'un jeune homme inquiétant une
personnalité impulsive intolérante à la
frustration donc quand il est dans une
situation qui le qui le provoque il
devient violent donc on a quand même une
personnalité qui est inquiétante par
certains côtés impulsif colérique certes
mais Mohamed Shahi a-t-il vraiment le
profil d'un tueur d'une cruauté hors
norme depuis son box l'homme répète
inlassablement qu'il n'a pas tué
Marjoline et sa fille d'un côté on a
Mohamed shib qui continue à à crier son
innocence de l'autre on a une accusation
qui avance pas à pas avec des faisceaux
de présomption mais qui n'a pas la
preuve ultime qui n'a pas laadn qui na
pas de témoin qui n'a pas d'aveux après
3 jours de débat le verdict tombe
Mohamed shib est condamné à 30 ans de
réclusion
criminelle pour la mère de Marjoline
Lalande c'est un soulagement ah ben il
prend 30 ans moi je suis contente bon il
aurait pu prendre plus j'aurais été
contente encore mieux mais pour la
famille de Mohamed shib ce verdict est
incompréhensible on s'est dit
euh mais mais pourquoi ils ont donné
cette condamnation pourquoi ils ont pas
fait l'acquittement quoi ah ouais dans
la tête c'était ça pourquoi ils ont pas
bien vu que c'était pas lui quoi Mohamed
shahib fait appel et ce n'est que le
début d'un long feuilleton
judiciaire en 2010 et 2011 deux procès
sont successivement renvoyés le premier
à cause de l'absence de témoins capitaux
le deuxième à cause d'un incident
d'audience nous sommes le 6 février 2012
à Carcasson Mohamed Chib comparaît pour
la 4è fois pour le meurtre de Marjoline
lalland et saphire c'est le procès de la
dernière
chance pour sa défense il a fait appel à
une star du barreau é Dupon Moretti et
pour l'avocat le dossier est vide
l'enjeu du procès c'est que on constate
que cette enquête est est calamiteuse
que des pistes n'ont pas été exploité et
qu'on se rappelle des règles qui sont
les nôtres
voilà que le doute profite à l'accusé
bien sûr que l'EN jeu c'est
l'acquitement bien sûr que c'est le
procès de la derière chance bien sûr que
nous savons que que que l'acquitement
est de plus en plus difficile parce que
l'acquitement par la justice sera le
désaveux de cette justice pour la
famille de Marjoline ce 4è procès est de
plus vous savez j'étais arrivé
franchement j'en pouvais plus j'en avais
marre ce que je voulais c'était que ça
se termine pu que on essaie de passer à
autre chose parce que bon ça fait 7 ans
que ça dure l'histoire dès l'ouverture
des débats rachidsour le père de saphire
et mohamedib s'affronte dans la salle
pass son temp à dire je sais pas quoi
vous dire puis un moment Rach lui dit à
vous à vous parceautement je vais te
tuer
Mamed Rach c'est pas moi qui
tuon ton fils c'est pas moi qui ai tué
ta
femme pendant les 8 jours d'audience les
avocats de shahib soulèvent les failles
de l'enquête et les zones d'ombre ils
veulent convaincre les jurés que les
constatations d'usage ont été mal faites
et que le meurtrier n'est pas dans le
box relevé de l'empreinte digitale qui
n'ont pas été opéré sur la poignée la
porte d'entrée de l'appartement relevé
d'empreinte digitales qui n'ont pas été
euh mené sur le cordon électrique qui a
servi à étrangler le petit saphir sur le
plan des constatations le boulot sur une
échelle de 0 à 20 c'est 0 les avocats de
shahib dénoncent aussi les pistes
négligées comme celle par exemple de
Yannick souvenez-vous ce jeune homme qui
se serait vanté d'avoir été chez
marjolen le soir du meurtre on a je le
rappelle ce ce Mo qui porte l'ADN de
Marjoline donc elle a elle a fumé ceegoo
et l'ADN d'un homme non identifié et ben
est-ce que vous pensez que le policier
de Bézier a eu l'idée de demander l'ADN
de de ce jeune homme bah non la Cour
examine ensuite le fameux nœud qui a
servi à étrangler saphire l'enquête a
révélé que c'était un nœud d'équitation
que Mohamed shaiib savait
faire mais appelé à la barre les experts
ont doute et alors à l'audience on fait
citer deux spécialistes de
l'équitation et là on est bien convaincu
que on va avec ce
nœud serrer la culpabilité de Mohamed
shaib et la première dame on lui montre
le nœud elle dit mais non pas du tout
c'est pas un nœud d'
quitation et là on voit l'avocat général
décomposé arrive le deuxème témoin cette
dame regarde dit non pas du tout c'est
c'est pas un
d'équitation le public commence à douter
de la culpabilité de Mohamed shaib Après
les pldoiries des avocat les jurés et la
cour se retirent pour délibérer un
délibéré anormalement long
extraordinairement long plus de 7 he et
à minuit et demi c'est enfin l'énoncé du
verdict Mohamed SHB a été condamné à 30
ans de réclusion criminelle la mre de la
accusé quitte la salle folle de
rage il y en a marre il y en a marre
mais
je jamais jamais je vi jusqu'au
[Musique]
bout et là je défend un innocent pas
coupable je suis de merde mer
merde de voir souffrir mon fils d'une
chose qu'il n'a pas fait
qui veulent pas croire à son
innocence il y a un vrai doute dans
cette affaire un vrai doute on a
sacralisé une enquête qui est un champ
de
ruine pour les familles des victimes
c'est la fin d'un long marathon
judiciaire qui aura duré près de 7 ans
un soulagement mais mais quelque chose
de on a gagné enfin enfin on s'est pas
battu pour rien parce que ah non moi je
baissis les bras franchement
Baer les brasvis plus le lendemain du
procès les avocats de Mohamed annonc
qu'ils vont se pourvoir en
cassation l'affaire des meurtres de
Marjoline Land et de saphir n'est
peut-être pas
terminé